okay good afternoon everybody and
welcome to this licensing actor
subcommittee it's in respect of an
application for a new premises license
for Quinton's kitchen limited Quinton's
cafe Joe's goal for an activity park
Joe's road of Coronado Sudbury the
hearing will take the form of F around
the table discussion the applicant will
well first of all will it will hear from
the licensing officer with the
application the applicant will have his
moment to put his case over and then
objectors will have their turn to put
their matters forward there will be
opportunities to ask each other
questions but I should remind you that
the questions should just be questions
and in relation to the representations
made here today the committee will then
retire to to come to a decision it's
moving on to the second item on the
agenda which is the election of chairman
conniver a nomination for chairman
please I'm not keen on it councilor sue
carpenter
the second thing thank you a future
firstly I need to read to you something
bad of a drastic arrangements the
meeting will be broadcast live to
YouTube and will be capable of repeated
viewing the entirety of the meeting will
be filmed except for confidential or
exempt items if you attended the meeting
in person you will be deemed to have
consented to being filmed and that the
images and sound recordings could be
used for webcasting and training
purposes the council members of the
public and the press may record film
photograph or broadcast this meeting
when the public and press are not
lawfully excluded so if any of you do
not wish to be identified in that manner
it's probably best that you go to the
back of the chamber I'm going to ask the
government officer to read the domestic
arrangement
Thank You chair toilets are situated
outside the meeting room across the
corridor water is also available outside
the room if the fire alarm sounds please
leave the building immediately via a
fire exit and make your way to the
assembly a point which is if switch town
football ground at the building behind
follow the signs directing you to the
fire exits which are at each end of each
floor
do not enter the atrium and do not go
down the stairs if you're in the atrium
at this time of the alarm follow the
signs to the nearest fire exit use
stairs not the lifts do not re-enter the
building until told it is safe to do so
please switch off all mobile phones or
tell them to silent thank you store
absence or substitutions are there any
declarations of pecuniary or non
pecuniary interest from either of the
council's thank you some introductions I
am the chairman for this committee today
and I am counselors do carbondale to my
right is councillor John Donne and
councillor Michael Hall thank you and
will the offices also please introduce
themselves
hello I'm Nigel ooh I'm the legal
adviser to the subcommittee David Price
licensing officer
Catherine Green licensing officer Karen
Sayer governance officer thank you with
the applicant please introduce himself
yeah yeah my name's Martin on the
applicant thank you have you received
the procedure the report and all the
relevant documents that you need yes I
have thank you other persons would you
please introduce yourselves Thank You
Stewart Alsop local resident Michael
Evans local visiting patient all their
submissions at this point
thank you so we have to ask my questions
now to the licensing officer firstly
have there been any requests from the
parties for permission to call witnesses
no dear
have the parties indicated they wish to
present documentary or other material
yes dear I'll take this in two parts if
I may I'll start with firstly
documentation that's been submitted
today by one of the other persons and
it's then down to the applicant to
determine whether to accept or reject it
before you get to see it and then I will
deal with the second part of the
documentation there's been committed so
you're saying there's more information
or material come through today that no
one has seen yeah no one has seen it yet
it's down to the applicant too and all
parties here to accept it before it gets
to mr. Quinton you can decide if you
want to see this evidence if you want
the committee to see this evidence or
not you can you can choose presumably
it's against the application
you have you have the right to accept
all or not oh that's a decline you
decline in which case we do not see it
okay check the second documentation was
documentation submitted prior to the
hearing date and if you'd like to go
through your decision on each one Jared
would you okay so we start with the
summary report of noise accepted or
rejected the summary report on noise
which one specifically was submitted by
the applicant was this the decibel
report and and some and some paragraphs
to it I think no we do not accept that
it is it's not regarded as something we
could validate thank you chair and the
letters of support also submitted by the
applicant applicant no but the applicant
can refer to those as hearsay if he
wishes in his own submission thank you
Jeff and there was a recording submitted
by one of the objectives we find that we
can't accept that
thank you chair there was an additional
paragraph that I suppose submitted to
yourselves on noise 12 travel and again
we cannot accept that and lastly chair
there were photographs submitted by one
of the objectives they hope they have
been seen but we cannot accept them for
the hearing thank you Jeff
mr. Quinton how long do you think you
will need to make your case do you like
to give us an indication of timing you
know it's about five minutes five
minutes the can I take it that you are
objecting to the application before of
you have you appointed a spokesperson to
speak for you right so are you kind of
different groups of people who are
objecting we are direct neighbors well
in fairness to the applicant we would
normally allow that the objectors the
same amount of time that the applicant
has to make a case I could be a little
lenient on that but it would ask you
please to be very brief it would be
preferable if you could appoint a
spokesperson but if you all want to
speak you can really only have two or
three minutes each
well how long do you think you do need
asked us how much time we would expect
to need obviously what we don't know is
whether that included any reply or and
but I put down for instance 50 minutes
it might be 10 it may be more unless the
question we were answering within the
act that we're doing the response to
yourselves
not that our time was limited by the
time given to the yeah it doesn't any
questions that you might be asking
doesn't come out of time that we can
give you but if you all wanted a quarter
for now that would make this a very
lengthy process I don't disagree with
what you're saying but I mean the term I
I quite I know it's used a lot when in
precision sees you know justice must be
done and justice must be seen to be done
I mean I would condense as much as I can
and if of course anything safe are my
colleagues he's repeating what I would
say then I wouldn't obviously ask the
same question regulations we must be
fair to all parties and they must be the
same timings yes would you like to just
confirm that from the legal perspective
yes I mean fairness is the overall
factor in this matter however it is not
reasonable to hear the same objections
over and over again the the general
consensus of the the written
representations relates to more or less
the same things I think is reasonable we
don't have to have exactly the same
amount of time but we have to be
reasonable and keep these meetings as
succinct and to the point that's
possible we don't have a strict regime
that we will cut you off at the very
death but but I think it's reasonable to
to make sure that you keep to the point
and don't have an extortionist amount of
time compared to the applicant so it's
really that the the chairs discretion as
to if after the first representation
someone else he's repeating the same
things and that's unnecessary because
they heard it and they've taken that on
board so they may you may be asked to
wind up unless you have any other
matters to raise I think I'll let you
choose who to go first if you bear in
mind what we're saying about time it may
be that if others I will let you all
speak but if you do I may cut you short
if I think this is going on too long
while you're repeating all right so
would you like to decide amongst you who
wants to speak first because I was in my
property was damaged and vandalized so
if there was any allegations made
against me I wanted to be able to refute
okay we have read the written
submissions
mr. Evans do you want to go first we
could take the seat now speaking just
get the yes and when the time comes you
will need to press the silver button on
the right that's in front of you okay so
that we that was really just to sort out
that the timings we're now going to the
hearing itself and first of all I'm
going to ask the licensing officer to
summarize the matter under consideration
thank you Jeff I will bounce around from
the offices report so bear with me
this hearing is determined and
application made for the grants of a new
premises license made under Section 17 a
little icing at 2003 for Quinton's
kitchen limited in relation to the
premises of Quinton's cafe at Jones
girlfriend activity park the application
was received by lasting authority on the
second of nine 2019 and a copy of this
is attached to the report as Appendix A
the application made has been subject to
the static consultation period as
prescribed by regulation and notices
advertised the application had been
displayed at the premises and published
within the West seventh mercury the
information provided with the
application outline so that the sale of
and supply of alcohol for consumption on
the premises only recorded music both
indoors and outdoors and live music both
indoors and outdoors are proposed as
part of a cafe located on the golfing
range for details of pros activities
timings and steps proposed in the
operating room schedule are contained
within the application form also
attached to this report as Appendix A a
hearing is necessary to determine the
application for receipt of relevant
representations which had not been
redrawn the lasting authority must carry
out his functions under the Act with
approved writing licensing DEP tips
which are stated below
in carrying out its lasting functions
the lasting Authority must have regard
to its statement of licensing policy
published under Section 5 of the Act and
any guidance issued by the Secretary of
State under Section 118 where revisions
are made to legislation or guidance
issued by the Secretary of State there
may be a period of time when the local
statement of licensing policy is
inconsistent with these envisions in
these circumstances the licensing
authority will have regard and give
appropriate weight to the reverend
changes guidance and his own state and
lasting policy the subcommittee will be
also aware of Human Rights Act 1998
considerations for civilly article 6 for
the applicant and articles 8 and 1 of
protocol 1 for those raising
representations or any terminal
applications for the grant of the new
license section 1 point 9 of the
council's David Larsen policy guides of
the licensing process can only seek to
control those measures within the
controls of the licensee or certificate
holder lashing is not a mechanism for
the general control of antisocial
behavior by individuals once they're
away from such premises and beyond the
direct control of the license holder nor
is it a cure-all for the community
problems if a license holder has taken
all appropriate steps to pricing
objectives whilst carrying out the North
rise lascal activity and there is no
causal link established between problems
issued in their locality and pacific
premises then it is unlikely that a
licen process of mechanism into existing
public nuisance is given the statutory
meaning in many pieces of legislation
however a little icing at 2003 it is not
narrowly defined and retains its broad
common-law meaning
representations that the last thing
thought he has saved we have received no
representation from any responsible
authorities under the Act however
environmental health has a responsible
authority under the Act I've undertaken
mediation on their their errors concern
and the outcome of their mediation is
attached as an addendum to this report
there have been eleven representations
received by other persons and these are
attached as Appendix B to this report
members of the subcommittee will be
aware of the status tree guidance at
paragraphs fourteen point six four and
fourteen point six five which states
that planning and licensing are
different ratings and neither are
bounded by the others decision there are
circumstances when a conditional
Planning Commission a terminal error has
been set for the use of the premises for
commercial purposes where these hours
are different from the lasting hours the
applicant must have reserved the earlier
closing time premises operating in
breach of their plan information would
be liable for prosecution and the
planning law the subcommittee must have
in regard to representations made raid
takes us to the steps if any as it
considers appropriate for the price
analyzing objectives and these are to
grant the license subject but the
conditions which is consistent with the
operating schedule accompanying the
application modifier to such myths came
as the authority considers appropriate
for the price in the last objectives and
subject to any inventory conditions
which must be included in the license or
to to exclude from the scrape of license
any last for activities to which the
application relates three to refused to
specify a person in the license as the
premises supervisor or tween four to
attack the application for these
purposes conditions of the license and
modified if any of them are altered or
omitted or any new condition is Eddie
and any party aggrieved by decision of
the lasting authority and respect to
this application there's a statue right
of appeal from that straight school and
that concludes the officer's report
Thank You mr. Quinton do have any
questions of your licensing officer
would you like to ask any questions of
the licensing officer Thank You mr.
Quinton would you like to present your
case to us yes thank you Jeff and so I
took over the running of this cafe now
known as Quinton's in December 2018 I'm
the owner of the golf site vanessa has
kind of given me the opportunity to run
my own business which is brilliant and I
just like to take the time to point out
that I'm nothing to do Vanessa were
completely separate legal entities and I
feel that unfortunately I've perhaps
been tarred with the same brush of
previous behavior that Vanessa may or
may not have there's a bit of history
between the locals and Vanessa I just
want to make it clear that that's
nothing to do with me um Vanessa
Woodward yes sir she's the owner of the
golf course and itself um I think the
biggest problem with well the biggest
reason for the representations is the
the hours of the license I want to taste
opportunity to assure everyone that my
Cafe opening hours will remain as they
are which is 9:00 to 5:00 and the
licensing hours till 10:30 was I include
that in the application to cover me for
anyone off events and that may or may
not going forwards today I've had three
events that have all done under
temporary event notices they were all
filed in the correct way and there were
no representations made by the local
authorities two of those events were
during the day one of those was in
evening in my opinion all three of them
went very well the event on 15th of June
which was the evening I was conducting a
perimeter check as I was doing every
hour I'm the music of the evening was
turned up about quarter to 10:00 once
everyone had finished eating the
barbecue on my prima walk with my
mother-in-law at 10 o'clock we decided
that the music volume was too late and
then on our way back to inform the DJ to
turn the music time we were met with a
resident who is here today who expressed
the same concern that the music was too
late
I informed the rest of that we agreed
and we're on our way back to turn the
music thing which we Julie did I'm
following that I had no further
objections or complaints that evening
and I think that this demonstrates that
I am able to uphold what's in the
license application with regards to the
objectives and with the further
objectives and that was suggested by and
the Environmental Protection team I
think there's a concern that perhaps the
locals believe I do not care about the
noise levels which is it's hurtful but I
do understand and I do understand why
they have concerns I would just like to
take this time to point out that we were
approached by a modified car group I'm
to hold a car meet on our site um the
provisional sort of numbers what you're
looking at sort of 100 to 200 cars
wanting to come onto the site or willing
to pay five planes ahead so from a
business point of view that would have
been a you know ignoring the potential
revenue from food sales that would have
been a nice little earner um we the
nester and I sat down and decided that
actually no that wouldn't be appropriate
it wasn't in keeping with the site and
fundamentally it would have caused far
too much noise and nuisance to local
residents so we can't he declined I mean
the events I intend to hold going
forward are I'm trying to they're gonna
be in keeping with the site so we're
talking more kids birthday parties golf
days we've got a recently got a golf
professional that's started doing some
lessons on site and we're hoping to have
some golf dates going forward
and we had a retirement party that was
that was quite good but I'm certainly
not wanting to turn it into a festival
or a rave venue because again it's not
in keeping with the site I mean you can
see on page 33 with the map we're not
necessarily right next to anyone but we
are aware that we are in the countryside
and noise does travel and so from my
point of view I'm willing to you know I
have in my opinion done everything in my
power to sort of mitigate any noise a
nuisance but I did invite the local
residents into the cafe to having a
conversation over coffee and to sort of
talk through any concerns or issues that
they may have had and I thought it went
quite well so it was heartening to see
that there were further objections as I
representations made since that meeting
I noticed that there is a couple of
representations in respect of children
being exposed alcohol I think one risk
and implied that after around a foot
both children may walk into the cafe and
be exposed to people drinking alcohol
I'd like to sort question what sort of
restaurant and pub Lee nowadays that's
not the case as someone who has an
experience working in restaurants and
pubs you know I fully understand the
need to have policies in prayer in place
such as challenge 21 and all my staff
are already trained to to see one stick
to that and so although there are
residents here who do object there are
also people in the local community who
are all for the cafe sort of growing and
getting this alcohol license and a lot
of our golfers especially remarkably are
perhaps the only Golf Course not to have
an alcohol license am i appreciating our
view have seen inside the cafe but is a
30-30 cover so 30 seats is quite a small
cafe and we're very much looking to do
I'm the old bottle beer and perhaps a
glass of wine with roast dinners that we
do on Sundays we're not we're certainly
not going to advertise it as a venue to
come and you know have a drink it's not
going to be a pub so alcohol is very
much ancillary to the food sales and
yeah as I've said I'm fully aware of my
responsibilities under the license of
the licensing objective
and I'll do everything I can within my
power to uphold them I'm fully aware
that should the license be granted today
I'm fully aware that it can be taken
away as easy as it's been granted so
it's certainly been my best interesting
you know I think the locals happy and if
that's with noise mitigation which I
mean as you can see from the additional
objectives included by this
Environmental Protection Team sort of
fully taken on board all the suggestions
made by them and with the view to have a
noise management plan going forward I
think I think that's it for me or any if
I just start off can you give an
indication at the moment at the level of
activity that is going on at the site
its business has grown since December
2019
but it's certainly not as busy as
perhaps it could be we we have a good
breakfast trade with the builders coming
in and then we have a nice lunchtime
trade normally starts about quarter to
1:00 and ends at half to business then
it drops off significantly from them and
there's pedometer golfers that come in
in the mid-afternoon
we run a couple of evening sessions well
our cafes used on a Tuesday and a
Thursday evening for a special needs
group who come and use the golf
facilities as you know just it just to
get them out of the house and again that
there rest by centers they they do what
a wide range of things from golf to arts
and crafts and they use the cafe free
have charged you know to shelter from
the British weather I suppose
what kind of percentage growth would you
expect that activity on this site to
increase
and to make it viable you know it's not
gonna be a substantial increase I'm
fully aware of the limitations you know
purely looking at the size of the cafe
if if we have a Sunday lunch I mean the
most people have served on the Sundays
we had 26 people booked in that this is
all Sunday lunch 12:00 to 3:00 and that
was just purely from the size of the
kitchen though that we've got that was
almost maximum capacity for me so we're
not talking hundreds of covers a day and
I would certainly like to see it improve
in terms of percentage growth I can't
honestly answer that because the trade
is so very different what about Jim
you're talking about a marque and hiring
job for events yes to what extent does
that go to increase include an
application of I've got limited to 12
events per annum at the moment we've
we've had a few interested parties have
wanted a higher rate for children's
parties whilst there are 12 events in my
license for the year I'm fully aware
that a lot of those who perhaps gonna
fall within summer the cafe is a
family-run cafe I work I run it with two
members of staff so we simply don't have
the resources to be doing weekly events
at the moment is very much a source uh
conceived process it's more for example
we are hosting the little corn on
Finnish barbecue which again is it's not
it's not a moneymaker for us all the
proceeds that go into the village hall
fund but it it's it's to try and sort of
advertise us as a site and to perhaps
give something back because I live in
little corner so you know I sort of
jumped at the opportunity to host er
this year going forward I I don't I
don't know we've had a lot of interest
and for children's parties you want to
do some foot golf and then have a
barbecue in the marquee I mean the
largest party we had was on the 15th
which we had 67 people and that for me
was maximum capacity in the marquee
it was it was you know it's just for
comfort for everyone actually being able
to serve that amount of people that was
a lot of concern is obviously about
music generate the outdoor music and
under what circumstances are you likely
to be using outdoor music depending on
the function or the party my plan going
forward is to well in the market what
the way that self is the music speakers
or project back into the cafe so away
from the residents to try and mitigate
any self and noise noise related
nuisance to put a number on the amount
that we expect I I haven't I haven't set
myself a limit if you like but also as a
such early days I don't know what the
uptake of is going to be at the moment
it is a very temporary sort idea it was
suggested by one of our reservoir one of
our regular customers who wanted to host
her kids princess theme party and we
thought okay it's not going to be every
week because I can't handle it's a lot
of stress and and preparation and during
the evening you're always conscious
about noise and these premature chinos
it's great to have and it's it's a lot
easier to do the ones during the day and
I think that's perhaps a bit you know a
bit more relaxing for me and so the
evening ones I'd certainly want to limit
those and certainly I wouldn't be
wanting to have you know yeah 18 19 20
year I was for parties just cuz wasn't
too long ago that was me at partying I
suppose and that's not perhaps what is
in keeping with the sigh or indeed the
cafe and we're trying to get more family
sort of thing rather than a late night
party venue because it's not we're not
cell for that
have a couple of questions about the
premises themselves we've seen a
photograph of an untidy derelict looking
area how accessible is that to people
coming onto the site especially children
and what are your intentions okay um so
that is in in the far corner of the site
um it's off it's next to car park so if
you saw visually I should come into the
car park why names you've got this
building which is Vanessa's not really
anything to do with me and then the rest
there to be park it's very much away
from it I'm Vanessa unfortunately um has
had a string of unreliable building
contractors with both of our special
needs center who she's wanting to build
on the site
I also with this storage shed
I'm so not answer to your question at
the moment and there's nothing to stop
me from walking over there but people
have come to the site for Goldford come
into the cafe they have no reason to go
to that area I'm just looking at your
map again and my colleagues may have
some questions for you on this also
there's an indication of where the
marquee would be I'm looking at page 33
there's an indication of where alcohol
sales and consumption would take place
but then alcohol consumption is
identified by a dotted line around the
whole of the the area is it your
intention that that should also be an
area for alcohol consumption um this was
following discussions with the licensing
team to allow and golfer's if they
wanted to take a drink around the gulf
side with them that's what that is for
that's perhaps not what
Vanessa's happy with that Zoe I put it
on the application but that could be not
just golfers that could also be people
coming to an event who decide to have
wander around take drinks outside yeah I
mean the the actual paddock area is
enclosed and to get through to the golf
course chef's go through two gates
I mean if we've got an event on there we
do we are mindful of keeping people in
the paddock or in the cafe um but yes I
mean I don't think there's anything to
stop them perhaps from venturing out
there questions yeah yep you mentioned
very early on and you said you are not
linked in any way you're separate
entities and yet you referred to a
couple of times in one reference economy
we almost refer to the fact you have to
get a permission we'll discuss with the
weather you were going to do it or not
someone will be confused and also you
just make some room but it's just now
about the outline area for the alcohol
consumption so can you just clarify it
is it a business relationship are you
responsible for the golfing side of the
business as well are you just
responsible for the cafe to say that
you're not together and then refer to
her a couple of times just a bit
confusing so if I could just clarify
that point for me please yeah of course
so we are completely separate vanessa
runs the golf course and i run the cafe
and with certain events like the car
meet for example or foot golfers they
come to the site to do an activity and
then i get brought in to discuss food
and the catering side of things so it's
not a case of i have any sort of
interest in the golf courses such an and
vice versa okay so if Vanessa want to
run a function she would approach you
with that idea for you to facilitate
that and she would give me their number
or email address Navon liaison them
directly another question you mentioned
challenge 21 but in your
application you have got challenge 25 I
assume there's just a little slip of the
tongue so to speak it will be challenge
25 it will be challenge 25
months you estimate that music will be
played it will certainly be infrequent
he's talking late at night which is
generally during the day I've I mean I
can't put a number on it and I wouldn't
want to tie myself to a number but it's
certainly not going to be frequent and
it will you know try to be as unimposing
and in terms of timing as possible music
is only going to be played when there's
a marquee event yes that's correct
how many marquee events and my
limitation is per annum which is 12
music going to be paid twelve times in a
month yeah yet correct in a year
potentially well it's it's four events
so whether it be alcohol sales or or
live or recorded music and there's a
potential 12 times yes outside music yes
obviously I've still got the background
music being played in the cafe but
that's purely background music where you
mentioned that the meeting that we had
early on in May where we had a
subsequent meeting further on in the
31st one of those things that you
mentioned there's that you would talk to
the local residents about upcoming
events when it came to June the 15th and
you had your tens event I it was me who
was came to you in the road in jaj Road
and approached you and
mother-in-law and I my question to you
then was why weren't we informed and
that was born from your original
statement of that you would talk to us
about these events and your challenge to
me was that you didn't have to inform us
it wasn't your you didn't need to do
that which was a direct change of
attitude to what we thought was quite a
acceptable approach and I just wondered
what is going to be your plan for
telling the local residents about these
events so we can brace ourselves yes and
just for clarification that the the
question you asked I believe was where
were those signs posted and my response
was under temporary event notices
there's no public consultation and it
was dance with the local authorities
honestly the reason that the the local
residents weren't told about the
fifteenth is I was very aware of the
hearing and I was aware that every
resident would likely have objected had
they have known in advanced so I wanted
to actually saw see and test the waters
in terms of volume sales incentive
volume and of course going forward the
residence will be aware but I would like
to ask I've noticed that your property
is on the market do you think that these
questions are more for concern about the
sale of your property right they don't
know better so answer your question
going going forward the residents you
know I do want to work with you guys my
you know I although I wasn't necessarily
around with when everything kicked off
if you like between Vanessa and
yourselves but Vanessa doesn't speak for
me and going forward I'm not here to
upset anyone I do it is hurtful you know
reading that the representations it was
hurtful and I would much rather well so
I think you've answered the question
to the applicant on on his application
if you would
with you on the 31st of May which you
cancelled so the communication has been
there from outside you can't solve the
subsequent meeting I just like that to
be on record thank you notice I about
the Marquise I'm sorry thank you
on page 33 of the application on your
the map shows a large area for the
Marquise which is much larger than the
actual Marquise that is on the site is
this just laying the ground for future
expansion to hold bigger and busier
events by marking this as such a large
area and thus potentially bringing more
and more traffic noise pollution
anti-social behaviour and crying to the
area just to respond to the council
meeting when when everyone arrived to
the site my wording was unfortunately
the meeting stays canceled and then I
was lost why and I said the purpose of
the meeting was to try and work with you
and mitigate any objections I was I
contacted the licensing team I was
informed that since that meeting there
are objections and also I heard from the
fishermen that you asked them to objects
the application and so that's that's
unfortunate why the meeting was canceled
yes sir regarding the the large blue
arrow and that is purely wedding in
closed paddock is and at the time of the
application you weren't sure where we're
gonna put the Marquis it's just like a
marquee you tape you put up and put down
um so that's indication as to the
paddock as I've said sort before it's it
this is very early days for me as a
business and for for the the Marquis
side of things
my intentions going forward it's not
gonna be the sort of venue which is
purely for events first and foremost it
is a golf course and it is a cafe on the
Golf Course the events are the things I
don't want to grow because I'm not you
know I'm not
it wouldn't be again it wouldn't be in
keeping with the site to have you know
weddings reception so in terms of growth
no I think you've answered the question
about that the question was about the
mark
so just to that direction we're talking
about here public safety I've paid a
visit to the site and in my experience
and knowledge from what Vanessa said the
premises hasn't had a fire risk
assessment carried out on it in the two
two-and-a-half years she's been there on
the evidence of what I viewed in
relation to fire extinguishers signage
there isn't any and fire extinguishers
have seen touch in the corner at a cafe
behind some water bottles we'd know saw
in each other my my point for that is
are you fully aware of the regulations
you should report for go under for the
recovery reform fire safety longer and
also has the marquee which has been
sitting outside for a good 18 months
been fireproof that would you know if
it's fireproofed should an incident
occur we had a gentleman come out and
doing a health and safety and fire
advisory but the fire safety side of
things is under my lease covered by
Vanessa so that is Vanessa's
responsibility as far as I'm concerned
again I'm leasing the the marquee so I
can't answer that question in terms of
fire safety but there's no open flames
or anything like that near the marquee
so I would expect most fires don't miss
you start from the flame they start from
electrical force and I do have that to
to
if your license was granted today by the
community would you be willing to
include your condition either by letter
drop or website if you have one to
notify residents of any events yes
absolutely
I've got a website in the process so
that could be an ideal and platform for
that as well as a layer job well yeah
sorry I meant mine changement study both
of those things and the other one I have
would you be willing to provide a
telephone number for complaints if there
was anybody living yeah absolutely
everyone who attended a meeting in the
cafe has my telephone number and some
residence he didn't attend also have
received that TOEFL number already
for that reason okay
can you just wait to this your turn to
make a representation we're just asking
questions a safety film a are you fully
aware when I'm sure you must be that the
area where the marquees stored he's also
used for splat ball for children to play
in which is great don't have a problem
but it's also used very frequently by
Vanessa's dogs I mean what guarantees
are there an area issues for children
and the public to go to events it's
going to be on any closed area which two
or three dogs are in all day long and we
obviously know the result but what
happens when dogs are left on a side
Vanessa keeps in there I know this is
unfortunately unfortunately Vanessa's
not here as the site owner and these two
have got to work together and isn't
gonna work
a chair obviously the only receptor from
the application in this hearing um the
splat ball was sold last summer and the
dogs but now she's she puts him in a
back garden and walks around the golf
course
because yeah I agree there was a concern
about the dogs going near the marquee
but that's all been nipped in the bud
from the outset yeah it's just um
perhaps the office of clarification that
check over there raised to concern about
fire regulations etc which I think the
captain sort of answered but are they
actually relevant to this licensing
application the first safety order is
obviously a separate piece of
legislation and not relevant
however the applicant must do a fire
risk assessment sorry have we had that
that's not something that we would get
anyway it would go to the fire so this
it's not part of this hearing
not really because we would be
duplicating another primary legislation
so um would you if it is a question to
us
so I worked in the busiest chef in
Brewer which is a pub chain for three
years which involved you know we have
private functions there all the time
with with numbers ranging from 20 to 30
people that would involved taking of
pre-orders and surf in an alcohol and
ensuring that anyone who appeared under
25 was ID'd accordingly and from that as
well I worked at a more high-end
restaurant where functions and weddings
were winning receptions rather where
frequently happening I'm so
uncomfortable I've got the experience to
manage a much larger scale than what I'm
proposing here and my life my pet my own
personal license was granted 15th of May
she has a 19 being the manager and
obviously conflict resolution sorry sir
just clarify I was a trainee assistant
manager at the pub I mentioned and
restaurant supervisor the second
restaurant I mentioned where I was
frequently having to deal with
confrontation and managing of people and
guess you won't have any further
questions
on the side because the whole site is a
licensing area they should be
accompanied by an adult is that going to
be possible I think it's I think it's as
possible at this venue as it is there
any other licensed venue I think you
know that's certainly as possible at
this venue as it is at any other
licensed venue years okay can I just
highlight in in the operation is
scheduled that under the protection of
children from harm it does say that
where events of activities are intended
primarily or excuse me presents a
variety the premises license holder
shall ensure no alcohol is available
there she'll would elicit children shall
only be permitted in the area the
premises being used for licensed
activities or events where accompanied
and under the supervision of an adult so
it is in the the operating schedule 15
acre or twenty acre site require alcohol
consumption over the whole with it it
just seems totally so you'll have your
chance to make a representation in the
minute since it's now your turn to make
your representation and bear in mind
please I don't want to go too long on
this because it's not fair to be ethical
six minutes in this bit psychic
now you'll find sorry we're just just if
you keep an eye on the egg timers
because we we do this
generally in committee so it's not just
to we okay we my primary representation
is about we our next board next-door
neighbors but one unfortunately between
us is is a lake now one of the
representations I I put forward and I
will refer to is that there are
scientific case studies out there in the
wild that say that water sound travels
further over water reason behind that is
that the air is called over a water body
and therefore the war the the sound can
travel further so in effect we may as
well be next to the Gulf Jose golf range
which is unfortunate because both my
wife and I are early risers and
subsequently we go to bed early now and
that's weekday and weeknight on the 15th
we we had a sample of what one of these
events was going to be when the site was
granted attends and to be absolutely
honest we we could hear it both inside
and outside of our house clearly we
could tell the what song was being
played we could tell whether we liked it
or not when I went up to talk to the
licensee applicant about the issue I I
met them on the road and the lady
accompanying you said that I should
appreciate the music because it's out of
my era which it wasn't I would like to
state and also surely I couldn't hear
that inside my house well actually I
could hear it both inside and outside my
house if that was true I could only hear
it outside does that mean I have to stay
in my house while you're having events
which I think that is totally unfair who
also puts me that actually there's a
that they lived near viewers Music
Festival and that's twice or three times
louder I totally accept that it's three
times louder but there only happens once
not one time of year and everybody knows
about it so I feel that my objections to
not only the noise which comes through
but the increased traffic the the danger
to the wildlife I've personally had the
scoop up ducklings off their side of the
roads this week not necessary to cross
girl French but you know this is this is
only get worse so I would really really
appreciate the fact that we are close
neighbors we can hear everything even
the dogs barking at the golf range so
let alone music and and I died on my
clear viewpoint of why I really do not
want late-night events happening at that
golf range which says that I I owe
concerns about the working practices of
the the management that he's doing on
the license part against the Gulf for
the center bearing in mind there is a
planning application which has been
passed to build a respite Center for six
people and more and their carers to
sleep overnight which nobody objected
against that we don't have that problem
but please where's the management
comfort here you've got one month's to
play music late into the evening and
somebody else just 3040 yards away on
the same site once to have a respite
Center and there seems to be some
confusion with that which we haven't had
an answer for secondly one has got to be
concerned they're following rules and
regulations we all have to do it but one
of them things was that you can't
advertise to bring people to the site
it's for golf people only in the cafe
yet signs have gone up on the a 134 on
adjacent signage
the the brown signage at the top of
Joe's road signs were screwed through
that sign to advertise that the calf was
on site and there are some on electrical
poles and telegraph poles along Joe's
Road all the things with the slight
small breaches but it does suggest is
this a pattern and then finally all I
would ask the committee is to consider
I'm sure you are aware of the case of
East Linsley District Council and about
a sniff in relation to crime and and
what drinking establishments can do and
it was in 2016 and another case stated
case was the an application at the Hope
and Glory public house v the City of
Westminster where air strikes that
license of premises and activities that
take place in these premises exist in a
Domenic environment and should not be
looked at it's highly in isolation which
is basically saying you should look at
the community how is it affecting the
community not just how is it gonna
affect somebody a minute away my final
question is we all know there's been 11
representations or myself working for
the residents Association what we are
not aware of is how many supporting
letters there were and in fact where are
them supporting people they live in half
a mile three miles away are they family
members that are supporting it are they
actually partners to the business that
are supporting it I think that really
matters that's my piece
isn't included in the timing but what I
would like to say relates to crimes and
incidents that have happened in the past
that have happened in the recent past
since Martin has been at the site I'm
not accusing you of anything I just want
to read through what I wrote
because I think it's really important to
get background how the president's
actually feel and the strain and the
stress they're living under because of
the owner of the site but also because
of this application they are intertwined
however much Martin would like to think
they're not they absolutely are and if I
don't read this statement I'm not
there's nothing really else I can add to
what Stewart and John have said I'm
going to advise the committee that they
will hear your statement I will give
advice on what weight that they should
give it
I mean regarding two to two incidents
that you're going to refer to as you are
aware or as you may not be aware one
resident has had his car and garage door
vandalized with the C word on his carp
on it and the word cafe and an arrow
pointing in the direction of your Cafe
Martin sprayed onto his garage door
Martin stated to myself and John Hills
that he believed the resident was
responsible for removing size that were
advertising the cafe and that Vanessa
ray Werth who owns the site stated that
it could have been one of the golf range
and/or cafe customers exacting revenge
as she had told them that this resident
had objected to her planning and was
responsible for moving the cafe size so
far no evidence has been proved been
produced to prove this resident did
remove these signs although you told us
sorry Martin told us that they were
behind the residents garage and that
there were photographs of them vanessa
ray were stated there was a video of the
resident removing the size but nobody
has ever seen any of this we I believe
your accusations are wholly unfounded
and that you are by saying and accusing
this resident of doing these things
partially responsible for what happened
to his car and garage door
as a consequence of what happened to the
residents car and garage door being
vandalized many residents have been too
scared to report any breaches or issues
at the site and were too scared to
object to the licensing application for
fear of retaliation many who did object
did so anonymously and are too scared to
attend this meeting this is an
incredibly serious issue for residents
who feel their safety is at risk and a
scared of repercussions Stewart's
already mentioned the comments that the
person we believe to be an Johnson
mailed to him although they may appear
to be packed just throw away comments to
us
that's actually really patronizing and
dismissive it comes across as
passive-aggressive and bullying and
intimidation and harassment like that is
just totally unacceptable and we haven't
now been barred from the site so we
can't even go and speak to them about
any of this okay thank you this is quite
a bit of information in that what I
would say that the subcommittee are not
aware of any accusations and they're not
something that they are here to consider
that the application is for a premises
license and the basis of the granting of
that premises license is that it does
not impinge on one of the for licensing
objectives they have to work on the
evidence that's been provided when I'm
sure that we understand that is there's
a lot of history here but I must
reiterate that the licenses subcommittee
can only consider what is proportionate
and relevant information on the balance
of probabilities and that's how they
will make their decision
I would advise them not to put too much
weight on the history although I do know
it's important to you but in respect of
this application I will be asking them
to focus their minds on the licensing
objectives and how the application will
hinge on that okay before you I'm sure
you have questions but I just like to
say now that you have a chance to sum up
and address some of the things that have
been said at the end so if any questions
now if they can just be questions rather
than coming back at things because you
will have an opportunity to say that the
opportunity to ask questions of what has
been said by you as objectors
would you like to you don't have to I
think anything that I would perhaps want
to ask or a talk with isn't relevant a
licensing objective so this moment I
think further questions
all right and and as you just heard you
do have the opportunity at the end to
sum up yeah I used that time thank you
um licensing officer any questions just
once or think again clarification on the
noise again it just officers is that
part of this application about the
environmental side of the noise impact
that this meatballs councillor dlc
protection of public nuisance is a
veteran factor the applicant has stated
steps proposed to you that he was
willing to deal with public nuisance
thank you if no one has any further
questions at this point we come to the
stage where I'll ask the licensing
officer to give a closing statement to
summarize any points which need clarity
where necessary so
or I will be brief obviously you have
the four last fugitives
the Frenchman Farrakhan disorder public
safety public nuisance and the
protection children from harm and making
a decision today to fight one of the
officers report so would you like to
make a closing statement yes and so as
awardee said I sort of explained my
intentions everything going for but I
just really want to hit home on the
point that I'm just trying to run a
business and I genuinely do not want to
upset any local residents and I know
it's not strictly relevant but for what
happened to mr. Evans's property there
is no excuse for that and I just like to
say it's time to assure you that I had
nothing to do with that I just it's I
don't want to turn the venue into a rave
city or festival venue it's supposed to
be I said in keeping with the site and I
I fully appreciate that if in six months
time if it isn't working it's not
working and I learn anything just want
to be given the chance and the
opportunity to show that I am a
responsible individual I do take on
board comments from the residents and I
am here you know my business is food and
making people happy and all those
cliches and and you know I certainly
take any other comments or anything else
I can do on board I'm sorry that you
know you know laid on the site but
unfortunately that's out of my hands
because again Vanessa she's not here
oh just on the point of the lake this
was a point I didn't raise the
Environmental Protection about how noise
travels at watering it an exception I
was advised of that wasn't that
concerned yeah I mean I'll produce
ramble for ages I just want to be given
a chance to show I can run a business
and and serve alcohol without you know
any any negative impact on the residents
and I believe I can do that I now leave
to read out further statement on the
basis that the subcommittee considers
that the public interest in excluding
the public outweighs the public interest
in its deliberation being held in public
it is resolved that under Section 108 4
of the Local Government Act 1972 the
public be excluded from the meeting for
item 13 on the grounds that it involves
the likely disclosure of exempt
information as defined in part one of
schedule 12 of the Act on the ground set
out in regulation 14 2 of the licensing
Act 2003 hearings regulation 2005 so at
this point I need someone to second that
motion it is second that motion Jay
thank you and we will now I would say we
would retire but I think we're going to
ask you to retire as we will stay here
and deliberate and we'll call you back
when we have a decision for you thank
you
you
thank you and welcome back we have come
to a decision and I'm going to ask mr.
Liu our legal adviser to read the
decision to you and to add any other
conditions thank you Thank You chair the
subcommittee have considered everything
that's been put before them today
written and and verbal and they do
realize that there is a history between
the residents and and the site but
they've had to consider the objectives
of the licensing and committee that the
licensing Act and in making those
considerations they have decided to
grant the license subject to conditions
which are consistent with the operating
schedule the company in the application
but also modified to such an extent as
the authority considers it appropriate
for the promotion of licensing
objectives those modifications come in
the form of the the four additional
conditions that were agreed with the
senior Environmental Health Protection
Officer together with a further
condition that the premises license
holder will publish notice of events on
the the website and by letter drop to
the residential premises on Jones Road
such notification will include a phone
number for contact for the the public
the premises license holder or the
person responsible for the event that
needs finalizing because we need to
we're not sure how far Joe's vote goes
obviously it needs to be extended only
to those that are affected so perhaps if
it could be agreed as to how far could
click anyway to me now I just need to
finish this there was also a variation
to the the extent of consumption of
alcohol on the site again this will need
to be finalized by the resubmission of a
plan but it's decided by the
subcommittee that the area of the golf
course should be excluded from the
consumption
and consumption of the alcohol should be
restricted to the the cafe area and to
the the paddock area in which the the
Marquis is situated and the reason for
this is that subcommittee feel that it's
difficult to monitor people drinking
alcohol
the further field using the golf course
there is a right of appeal to this
decision the applicant and any person
who's made a representation to the
subcommittee can appeal against the
decision or against any condition
imposed on the on the application on the
license that that application should be
made to the magistrate's court within 21
days than the day that the decision
notice is issued thank you very much did
you ask something
Sheepshead Hill the people who live in
Sheepshead Hill which is off shows our
members of the residents Association
also and can be affected so it's not
just Joe's Road it was cheap said he
always will I find lies yes yes if we
actually decide who is most likely to be
effective those in the immediate
vicinity I think at some point I saw
that there were 35 homes nearby but but
we will look at the properties that are
most most likely to be affected by the
noise and is that the property that we
see on its own opposite the range or
it's a different one okay right okay
well we'll make sure that we follow up
on those particular points so that some
that's the whole thought listed building
and we'll look at those properties that
are affected
thank you very much for attending and
I'm now close to meeting
you